- [Interviewer] All right, Ivy.
Welcome back.
So what's going on in your life
since the last time you were here?
It's been a month or so.
- I mean, crazy shit.
Bunch of crazy shit.
Yeah, I lost my daughter.
- You lost your daughter?
- Yeah, not lost her, but--
- But she went to--
- DCFS.
- [Interviewer] How did that happen?
- Her grandmother called on me.
And just basically told 'em that
she felt like I wasn't in the right
space to take care of my daughter.
- How do you feel about that?
- Angry.
Angry, upset.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
like you brought that on
because of the decisions you've made, or--
- I mean, yeah.
- How do you see it?
- Yeah, my decisions, I guess.
- [Interviewer] So who's
raising your daughter?
- Her grandparents.
Her grandparents are raising her.
- [Interviewer] And there's a chance,
if you've got your life
straight and together,
you might get her back?
- Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] And where
are you at with work now?
You're still working.
- Yeah, not as much as I was, but I mean,
I think I've been depressed, really.
So I don't get up as much.
So,
I really just sleep.
Yeah, I really just sleep a lot.
- [Interviewer] I ask that
question of pretty much
all the girls that come
in to do what you do,
and they all tell me they get
depressed from doing this.
It's not just you, I
think everyone kind of--
- Yeah, tired.
Angry, upset.
- [Interviewer] Do you view men
differently because of this,
the interactions that you
end up having, do you think?
- Men?
- Men.
Do you view men differently
because of this?
- No.
I view a certain type of man differently.
- [Interviewer] That's good
that you see a difference.
'Cause not all guys are--
- It's easier for me to
see people, like, I can tell like,
spirits.
People, I can get vibe, like, your vibe.
I can tell if you were like,
a man that raped me, or
I can catch on quickly,
if you're just, you know.
- [Interviewer] Your intuition must be
very sharp.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
talk with your daughter?
- Yeah.
I see her, I visit her,
and,
I video call her and stuff.
I just gave her some
clothes the other day.
- [Interviewer] Now, a lot of
your siblings are in prison,
right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You
told me that last time.
What do you think the chances are of you
getting out of this lifestyle and
living a--
- I'm either,
I'm either gonna do better
or I'ma die like this.
There's no
choices, options.
- [Interviewer] I mean, can
you imagine, like in 10 years,
your daughter will be
older, you'll be older.
And the decisions you make today
will really impact your,
your life heavily.
I mean, you're very young still.
How old are you?
- I'm 20.
- [Interviewer] You're 20.
You could make a decision today
that could change yours and
your daughter's life forever.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
There's programs that'll help me.
- [Interviewer] And some of it was
the childhood that you had
and the tough breaks you had early on.
So it's not like it's all your fault,
but still, it's gonna be your job to
process all that and dig out of it.
- Mm-hmm, yeah.
Still that's a tough topic to hit on,
when my daughter's talked
about, so it's like, kinda like,
that's hurtful.
- [Interviewer] What
upsets you the most about
working the streets, what's
the worst part of it?
- What upsets me the most is the men that
take advantage of us.
It comes with it, I mean, you know.
We don't deserve it, but,
but it's like,
why the fuck, like,
why would you rape or rob
someone that's already, you know,
that already has to do, not
has to, but chooses to do
something like this with their life.
It's ridiculous.
That's what upsets me.
The people that, that take from us.
- [Interviewer] Once you're
out there on the street,
pretty much everyone sees you guys as
just something to be used.
- Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] No one wants
to hear your whole story,
and how you got there, and why,
and what you're going through.
- Oh, no, most definitely.
No one gives a fuck, no one cares.
It's just what we're here for,
and let's get it over with.
'Cause those, the type of men and women
that pay for sex, it's like,
that's obviously something
missing in them, too.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So everybody has something
they fill their void with.
- [Interviewer] Do you know,
do you have any of your friends
that do this, that have gotten out?
- Oh, yeah.
I wouldn't say friends, but I've--
- People you know.
- I've, yeah.
I've worked with girls on the streets,
and I see them like,
owning businesses now.
And--
- Do they seem happier?
- Yeah.
They seem happier.
It still affects them in certain ways.
It still like, takes a toll
on like, the way you do stuff,
the way you think about stuff,
the way you see people.
Everything is money,
money, money, money, money.
- [Interviewer] And do you
think you're addicted to
the fast money?
- No.
- No?
- There's nothing to be
addicted to. (chuckling)
There's nothing to be addicted to,
unless you're addicted to drugs, or
addicted to sex, or,
the money is,
there's way better
money to make than this.
Way better, man.
I'm personally,
I'm addicted to the family orientation.
'Cause if I feel like I
get out of the lifestyle,
it's kinda like, what am I going back to?
Really, just my daughter.
But it's like, my sisters,
my mother, my brothers, like,
I'm scared of like, losing
a support system, basically,
or not having a support system
when I want to get better.
It's just like, damn, am I
the only one I can rely on?
It's kind of, it's really scary.
Honestly.
It scares me.
- [Interviewer] What scares you the most?
- Only having myself to depend on
is,
is scary.
Who do I call on when I'm like,
almost there, when I'm ready to give up
and just kinda give up?
- [Interviewer] I mean, there
are challenges like this
for everyone in life.
And if you can have the courage to
decide, make decisions
for yourself that are
constructive, that are not destructive,
you can start seeing results,
in terms of how you feel about yourself
and what your quality of life is.
You may not make the fast
money that you're making,
but all kinds of great
things would come with it.
I mean, part of the problem might be that
nobody in your family
or no one around you is,
has made those kinds of decisions.
So you don't have a whole lot of examples
or role models of how to do that.
- [Ivy] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But just put, you know,
put yourself in your daughter's
position, and put yourself in her head
and imagine what she would want.
- Mm-hmm.
She would want her mom,
like I wanted my mom.
- [Interviewer] Exactly.
It's kind of up to you to break the cycle.
- Oh yeah, most definitely.
I just didn't expect to be a mom so early.
It's like, damn man, am I ready?
- [Interviewer] You're never
gonna be ready, you just do it.
All I can tell you is the
easy way out is never the way.
It's always going to be the hardest route
that's gonna end up being the right one.
That's across the board.
The easy way won't get you what you want.
- Yeah, most definitely.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Can you see yourself like,
20, 30 years from now,
doing this?
'Cause I've interviewed girls that are
20, 30 years older than you
that are still doing it.
- All I have to do is look at my mom.
- Yeah.
- And there it is.
There it is.
So, hmm.
'Cause I'm not,
I'm not gone.
I'm not,
I might be a little off,
but I'm not like, so way
out to the point where
there's no return.
So it's like, it's just a battle.
It's a battle.
It's just a choice.
- Yeah.
I mean, what I see in you is
more than anything is just,
your mood is so down--
- I get that a lot.
- [Interviewer] That that
must make it hard for you to
make good decisions for yourself.
But if you can force yourself to do that,
your mood might improve.
And then, it almost feeds
on itself in a positive way.
Like, one good decision leads
to another good decision
that leads to feeling
better about yourself,
which allows you to make
more good decisions.
And you can rebuild your life.
And get your daughter back and live a life
that is everything that
you wanted it to be.
Maybe not the fast money
of work in the street, but
certainly safer, more respectful.
Something that won't get you depressed.
Something that can lead to a relationship,
'cause it's going to
be very hard for you to
have a relationship with a man who
knows that you're doing this.
Maybe the kind of guy you want.
(chuckling) You can probably
have a relationship with a man,
but it won't be the kind
of relationship you want.
- Yeah.
'Cause, yeah.
I get that a lot.
I get that I'm like, I'm kinda
zoned out most of the time.
But it's...
(sighing) I don't know, maybe it's drugs,
or maybe it's just,
I'm tired of trying.
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] I think if you looked at
what choices you could
make right now in your life
and figured out which one is the most,
which one requires the most courage,
and chose that one, I
think you could probably
change the direction of your
life really beautifully.
And the problem is, most people around you
don't have the courage
to do anything like that.
They just wanna take the easy way out,
which keeps them stuck.
And you probably feel stuck.
- Yeah.
I feel like I've been stuck
since I was a kid, though.
I feel like it was always kinda like this,
this shadow that followed me.
It's like I was doomed for it
or something like, for bad,
bad or evil, like it followed me.
- [Interviewer] Well, courage is the way
out of that.
- Yeah.
Maybe I got used to it.
I'm used to just, like, my shadow.
I just kinda
sat with it, but I couldn't get out of it.
It just takes strength, that's all.
- [Interviewer] Well
darling, I wish you the best.
I hope you figure this out.
Cause you're, you're young,
and you're beautiful,
and you're smart.
You can do anything.
But it's gonna take some
hard work and courage.
And the shortcuts and the
fast life and all that,
won't get you there.
And maybe you never saw that,
'cause you didn't have role models around
to show you that, but
that's really the way out.
- Yeah.
For my daughter, yeah.
For my daughter.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I mean, you can
use your daughter as a reason
to do this, but really,
it's yourself that you should
use as a reason to do this.
Treat yourself as if you're your daughter.
What would you do for your daughter?
Anything, right?
You should treat yourself that way, too.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You know
how beautiful you are?
You're the most beautiful
girl I've had in here.
(chuckling) You really are.
Do you see yourself that way?
- (chuckling) Nah.
I'm cool, I'm pretty.
- Yes, you are.
- Pretty.
- [Interviewer] Just don't rely on that.
Rely on your courage and your strength.
- Yeah.